this is the danger bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
unto you thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Deen show and
today in the studio back with us again
dr. Lawrence Brown you go to the Deen
show calm to read about him he has his
own private section there he is a former
atheist who was trying very hard to be a
Christian who accepted Islam and by now
you know Islam simply means to acquire
that peace that we're all looking for
from the owner peace the one guy
submitting yourself entirely to him
that's what Islam means and he has
accepted Islam and he also has a DD
doctor in divinity PhD in religious
studies and he's here to talk about
another topic out of the several that
we've covered we've covered and proven
that Jesus peace be upon him whose dear
and beloved to our hearts was not God
never claimed to be God was in the Son
of God none of these things and you can
go back to his section and watch some of
these previous shows but in today's show
we're going to be talking about the
topic of Jesus now being the Lamb of God
what does that actually mean was he led
to the slaughter
did God go ahead and sacrifice him for
the sins of the world is this fact or
fiction we're going to clear the
confusion on this week's show with dr.
Lawrence Brown sit tight don't go
nowhere this is the Dean the Dean Jews
this is the thing this is the days is
the danger
this is the thing you know this is the
thing is 15 Jews continued mrs. the
angel
hey what's up buddy salami oh I like oh
sorry I had you go in there for a minute
huh for a minute we give those greetings
of peace because we want peace don't we
do we just want Peter we just keep
saying peace I haven't heard people
mention the word peace so much as the
Muslims do every time we greet each
other we're like peace be unto you when
we see each other when we're leaving
each other peace be unto you when we in
its peace peace peace but there's always
war and people attributing terrorism to
Islam and they you know they seem like
opposites what you comment on this
before we start into our topic actually
well it's interesting that you should
mention that because while you were
talking right now I was thinking about
when I got married yeah because when I
got married I was talking with another
brother about just the process of
getting married and you know having love
in the marriage and so on and he it was
just interesting to me he just kind of
sat back and thought for a minute and
said you know I think I would rather
have peace in the marriage than to have
love in the marriage mm-hmm I thought
that was really interesting at first I
was just thinking what are you talking
about but then when I thought about it I
realized you know you can have you can
have love in your marriage but it can be
a pretty stormy relationship yeah you
know and if you don't have peace in the
household if you don't have peace with
your wife it's going to destroy the
marriage it's going to destroy the love
but if you have peace if you have peace
with you and your wife or you know for
the ladies between the wife and the
husband the love grows on top of that
and you end up with both and it's the
same way with a lot of things you know
in Western society everything we look at
is reminding us of happiness you know
you look at a billboard everybody on the
billboard looks like they're having the
time of their lives they might just be
advertising a bottle of water but
they're making it look like you know I
mean they're just ecstatic about this
bottle of water yeah and it's the same
way with every advertisement newspapers
radios television everything is
projecting happiness as if our goal in
life is just to be perpetually happy but
that's not very realistic and the more
you fight for that goal the more elusive
it is you know we are we are trying to
be just perpetually happy and you can
never achieve that but what you can
achieve is you can achieve me at peace
with yourself with those around you and
at peace with your Creator now that's
something you can achieve and once
you've achieved that the happiness will
come with it we got to get our
priorities straight
because the foundation has to be strong
before you can build on it just some
good advice definitely definitely and so
we're breaking the ice a little bit and
we're getting it now to our main topic
now people again can go to your own
private section at the dentistry all
calm to see the previous top of your
conversion story why you accepted the
way of life we'll all the prophets of
God including Jesus peace be upon him
Islam now at that area you we also have
the topics of you proving beyond the
shadow of a doubt that Jesus peace be
upon him was not the only begotten Son
of God that he didn't have a divine
status that he wasn't God he wasn't the
son of God you proved this in the top 10
- top 5 the top 10 reasons and these
were some very exciting shows and I
really encourage everyone to go watch
those but this week's show we're going
to be talking about the Lamb of God
let's start what does this mean the Lamb
of God that Jesus was the land well
first of all I'm probably not the best
person to ask that question ask
Christians what do they mean
Lamb of God and see what they say yeah
because like many terms in
in Christianity most people just have
trouble with it yeah
what does Lamb of God mean what is the
holy spirit you know what what is the
comforter what at cetera et cetera
define define the Holy Spirit for me you
know define it most people have trouble
with these concepts so what we're
dealing with now is we are talking about
in this episode in previous episodes the
tenets of faith that upon which the
Christians and the Muslims differ so
we've talked about Jesus Christ being
the only he begotten and the son of God
the fact that none of these three
doctrines is tenable you know he's not
the only is not begotten he's not the
son of God we've talked about the
Trinity we have talked about the alleged
divinity of Jesus Christ in my book
misguided you'll see that I address 16
points okay so we're just touching on
basically half of those when we come to
the concept of the Lamb of God where
this comes from is this comes from John
1:29 where allegedly it is said you know
behold the lamb of God who takes away
the sins of the world and this is John
the Baptist identifying Jesus Christ as
the Lamb of God who takes away the sins
of the world well the problem with this
is that the word that is translated to
Lamb Tahlia actually that correct
translation from the Aramaic Tahlia is
servant not Lamb so the correct
translation would be behold the servant
of God now there's a huge difference
between servant of God and Lamb of God
but to try to make it fit within
previous scriptural harmonies the
translation was adapted to Lamb of God
to make it consistent with other
Scripture this is not this is not honest
this is not forthcoming this is not this
is not what we should be doing with
revelation
should be we should be you know clear
obvious and faithful to the scripture
and we're we to do that the correct
translation is behold the servant of God
now one point I would make about this is
that it's said that in John 1:29 John
the Baptist knows who Jesus Christ was
he says behold the lamb of God this
guy's the lamb we got right here hey
everybody lamb Oh God right here we got
them right here why then in Matthew 11 3
does John the Baptist say ah are you the
coming one or do we wait for another
okay now you can't have it both ways
either John the Baptist knew who he was
or didn't know who he was okay the
Christian claim is he knew who he was he
identified him as the Lamb of God and
said the Lamb of God who takes away the
sins of the world and we're pointing out
okay if you're going to say that then
why is that in Matthew 11 3 you know he
says to Jesus Christ are you the coming
one or do we look for another in other
words he doesn't really know who he is
mm-hmm okay so you have two big problems
here one is the mistranslation and the
other is that it's clear that whatever
John the Baptist is saying about him he
doesn't he's not certain he's not
certain if Jesus Christ is the foretold
one to begin with hold your place right
there we'll take a quick break when we
right back sit tight whatever Allah
commands eternal unique and his land has
tolerance and mercy and compassion
that Allah you know will forgive you as
long as you do what you need to do as
long as you turn back to him
Islam is a system of mercy and
compassion and it is for the best
benefit of all the people that surround
it Muslim and non-muslim
motion
back here on addy show with dr. Lawrence
Brown please continue on talking about
the Lamb of God short continuation the
only other thing that I would add is
that we find the concept of Jesus being
the Lamb of God only in the Gospel of
John so if you're going to weigh the
Gospels you have to say the Gospel of
John is the only one that gives anything
that can be kind of manipulated to have
this concept Matthew Mark Luke don't
even mention it so in essence you kind
of have three votes against one and even
the one vote the passage I already
discussed in John is extremely weak
because of the mistranslation now we
know as Muslims once who follow that way
of total and complete submission to the
one guy the same guy that jesus prayed
to that Abraham prayed to the one guy
who created the universe and everything
in it he created us in original goodness
with a fresh clean page from the start
yeah so we we don't believe that we're
stained that we have a stigma attached
to us more born but some people believe
in this this original sin and this
somehow ties into the Lamb thing what do
you got to say about this actually the
original sin ties not only into the you
know lamb Ness but it ties into all of
Christianity because if there is no
original sin then what is the purpose of
atonement what's the need for atonement
what's the need for the atoning
sacrifice of Jesus Christ if there is no
original sin so this is a very very
critical doctrine is their original sin
is there not original sin now in Ezekiel
18:20 we are told the son shall not bear
the sins of the father the wickedness
the wickedness of the wicked shall be
upon himself okay it clearly states in
Ezekiel 18:20 that sins are not
inherited okay and yet people say okay
well that's Ezekiel that's Old Testament
we're Christian we follow the New
Testament Ezekiel that's Old Testament
okay it's Old Testament no argument
there but you know what it's not older
than Adam it's not older than Adam
mm-hmm
the concept of original sin is that it
dates from who it dates from Adam the
sins the sin of Adam was inherited to
all of mankind
if original sin were a valid concept
none of the prophets throughout time
would have talked about it anywhere
anyway any time and yet you find Ezekiel
saying the son shall not bear the sins
of the father the wickedness of the
wicked shall be upon himself in modern
slang in modern English look how would
you translate this you know for the
people that you know kind of this old
English how would you translate this I
mean the translation is clear you cannot
inherit sins you cannot so sin is not
inherited I mean you would look at a
child and you'd look at the child and
you'd say that child is sinless who has
ever looked at a baby picked up newborn
baby and said aha while they just looked
so evil you know I mean never it never
happens who looks at a child who looks
at you a child they just come on come on
coming here sort of like sort of like
Jesus Christ
yeah when he said in Matthew 19:14 he
said let the children come unto me and
do not forbid them why why in his words
according to the Bible for of such is
the kingdom of heaven speaking of the
children yeah now if we have original
sin upon us if we have original sin upon
us if children have original sin upon
them how is he saying let the little
children come unto me and do not forbid
them for of such as the kingdom of
heaven so so if they have original sin
on them
you know for of such would not be the
kingdom of heaven yeah it's kind of like
an attorney you know saying you know
that my client is guilty as a newborn
child so you know you you're responsible
for yourself basically I'm responsible
for mine what my great-great-great
grandfather did if he did a crime you
can't come lock me up for it that's I
mean this is common sense yeah yeah oh
a so now so anything else you want to
add on the not only is count is a
common-sense but the point I'm making is
not only is it common sense but it's
contrary to Scripture okay all right so
anything else on the atonement that you
want to original sin that you want to
all of these things we can expand upon
more but you know for the purposes of
our description discussion today let's
move on okay now we have also that's
tied into it atonement you hear this
word also miss right I mean as we said
if there's no original sin there's no
need for atonement and all of the
doctrines that surround this are under
question the doctrine of the crucifixion
and so on
we as Muslims believe that that Jesus
Christ was not crucified but so it was
made to appear to the people okay but
that actually our Creator raised Jesus
up we do believe that he will come back
close to the day of judgment he will
vanquish the the Antichrist and he will
usher in an age of justice but this is
another story in in speaking of
atonement directly the issue of
atonement the concept of atonement comes
from 2 Timothy 2:8 okay and in this
verse it's this is taken from the letter
of Paul right and it stated remember
Paul is stating that remember that Jesus
Christ was raised from the dead
according to my gospel what is he saying
he's saying that Paul is saying that it
was according to his gospel that Jesus
Christ was raised from the dead where
else do we find it that's it now point
is I mean are you going to trust Paul
with your salvation when we know that
you know Paul is the only one who wrote
about the atonement the doctrine of the
atonement come comes from Paul and yet
Paul contradicted basically everything
that Jesus Christ said and did and was
when Jesus Christ taught Old Testament
law Paul
gated Jesus Christ talk accountability
Paul taught justification of faith Jesus
Christ taught that he was the son of man
Paul taught that he was the son of God
Jesus Christ taught pray to God Paul
said pray to Jesus Jesus Christ taught
that he was an ethnic prophet not sent
but to the lost sheep of Israel Paul
said that he was a universal prophet and
on and on and on most powerful thing
Jesus Christ taught God is one here o
Israel the Lord our God the Lord is one
3 times 3 times recorded in the Bible
and of course from Pauline theology we
get the Trinity what am i pointing out
I'm pointing out that you know you've
got Paul and Jesus like this no you've
got Paul and Jesus like this Paul and
James were like this Paul and Peter Paul
and Barnabas you not only had conflict
between the teachings of Jesus Christ
and Paul okay
disparate teachings contradictory to one
another but you actually had the
disciples of Jesus the true disciples
were in in open conflict with Paul open
conflict and yet and yet and yet people
look at the epistles of Paul and they
find the things that they want to teach
the atonement and they grab a hold of
that and they say okay you know we'll
believe in the atonement from this guy
who everything else he has done has
contradicted Jesus but we like this part
so we're going to hold on to it this is
so very very very selective selective
thinking I mean it's taking what you
want it's taking what you want because
you like it rather than taking the
reality I mean if you can picture now if
we can go into I just I have a lot of
questions on this you know for the
layman you know he's not really into the
Bible but you get a lot of people who
have a problem with this and people who
are born into Christian family you know
they want to do the right thing many
people are getting you know fed up with
the rat race of life and they want to
develop their spiritual side they know
there's a crater this is something
that's innate in all of us but this
whole concept they're looking for
something else because this isn't fit
you know so we give analogies I'm just
thinking you know you see
you can imagine like you know a father
is you know let's say walking with his
son you know and then all of a sudden he
pushes his his son in front of a car and
the Sun you know said you know dad dad
you know what you know saving me and
then sorry son you know this is for the
criminals that we got to let loose I'm
sacrificing you for all of them I mean
you know it's just kind of what we can
equate to where you know you know where
God is you know where the judge is
letting letting the letting the the
criminal go or letting his son go so the
criminals can get can get let loose
people who had you know yeah you know I
mean there are some people who say
you're thinking like a human being yeah
you're thinking like a human being
you're not thinking like God okay well
how else are we supposed to think yeah I
mean God gave us our minds to think in
this way yeah all right it makes I mean
it just makes sense that God gave us the
tools to understand what makes sense
yeah and so we understand that this
doesn't make sense
not at all we understand that you know
no son you know father would sacrifice
his son for the forgiveness of other
people for whom his son has no relation
yeah okay how does this relate to that
we all understand that but you know I
think what is going on is that the
concept of the atonement is just such an
attractive concept do whatever the heck
you want okay do anything you want to in
this life go ahead and just have a blast
forget the laws forget revelation forget
accountability to God forget prayer
forget the tenants of it do what ever
you want but just say I believe before
you die and you'll be forgiven
convenient yeah I mean this is this is
just this is taking a religion because
you like it
not because it makes sense not because
it's believable not because it's true
seems really easy and convenient and
let's take a break and we right back
with more here on the Disha okay from a
science major when you look at the Bible
says the earth has four corners
is this wrong if any Christian can point
out a single unaccomplished issue a
single unambiguous treatment where Jesus
Christ peace be upon him says say that I
am God or ye worship Me I am rate ratio
Christianity
back here on addy so with dr. Lawrence
Brown DD doctor and divinity PhD and
religious study went from being an
atheist trying hard to be a Christian
now you're Muslim Jesus was a Muslim
Abraham listen listen we're not the
Antichrist are you died intact Christ
someone might say hey man this guy's the
Antichrist here get away turn the TV off
I'm for Christ I am for everything that
Christ stood for and taught but the
point I'm making is that what Jesus
Christ did and said and was are very
different from how the church portrays
it we got a lot of points here we're
almost out of time fact or fiction tell
me this is what we're not making up
things people can go verify this but we
ask the people of an open heart open
mind tell me that Jesus peace be upon
him or his companions those that knew
him the best did they ever did Jesus
ever say listen and you have plenty
opportunities to say listen God sent me
as his son to die for your sins and if
you don't believe this you go into the
Hellfire it was a serious business yeah
yeah yeah did he ever say that no this
is an interesting point of course no he
didn't and and this is a you know this
is I think a very powerful point because
everything in the Bible suggests that
ISA lslam Jesus Christ knew of his
coming trial knew of the you know the
difficulty he would go through the trial
the persecution and the you know the
impending execution or attempt at
executing him okay so you know we find
that Jesus Christ tormented by what he
foresees coming okay now you just have
to assume that if he knew that he was
going to be paying for the sins of
mankind in a couple of days he was going
to be crucified he was going to be
resurrected and his atonement would
would wipe clean the slates of mankind
but he would have been telling this to
his disciples he would have been saying
to them look guys don't worry I'll be
back in a couple days and you know you
can just relax everything's going to be
taken care of nowhere does he say that
instead instead he continues and
continues to to bid his followers to
piety to righteousness and to the duties
of the faith such as prayer you know
nowhere did he say guys you can relax
you could slack off a little bit a
couple days everything's going to be
cool I'm going to I'm going to take the
burden from your shoulders mm-hmm and
his last dying words it just really
quickly was it did it seem like not I
mean what they say he's dying words you
know when he was on the cross when he
said Massa buck Tony what does that mean
translate to yeah but what were his last
words because one gospel says his last
words were it is finished and another
gospel says his last words were into
your hands I commend my spirit
yeah so again you can't have it both
ways
yeah one says his last words were and
the other says his last words were and
then they give different stories okay so
how how reliable is this this is one of
many many many many contradictions in
the Bible okay so how do we now key well
now the passage you quoted okay I mean
the translation of that is you know is
my Lord my lord why have you forsaken me
doesn't seem like saying that who's
ready to go out that actually is
blasphemous yeah okay we as Muslim say
we don't believe that he said that yeah
you know because that is blasphemous to
say my lord why have you forsaken me job
didn't say that Abraham didn't say that
yeah okay you know and you you have all
of these prophets I I use joke I mean
Abraham's an excellent example but I use
joke because he's the you know he's what
we always hold up as the example of
patience he never said my lord why have
you forsaken me and yet we are going to
say that Jesus Jesus Christ's faith was
so weak that he said that he believed
his Lord had forsaken him this is
blasphemy yeah
no you know no right you wouldn't expect
that from any righteous person much less
from a prophet much less from you know
one of the greatest prophets of mankind
or Abraham you calling me to sacrifice
my son showing weakness no they were
already willing and able obviously he
wasn't ready will enables allegedly for
what they're saying doesn't make sense
doesn't add up and you've disproved
these two
once again you know we love our brothers
in humanity and we're just trying to
relay the truth have people open their
hearts and minds and the truth shall set
you free it's very simple this is not
anything hard to comprehend where do
they go from here now you might have you
know really captured a lot of people's
attention but they hold on hold on we
just got a minute left
ha how do they make sense of it all what
what do you how do you replace it okay
you want me to say that in a minute yeah
bottom line is this you look at the
Bible we have spent a bunch of sessions
showing by showing why what you find in
the Bible is not always the Word of God
it's a terrible thing to tear down a
person's faith and not replace it so let
me just remind people of what they
should believe in we do believe as
Muslims that the Word of God is in the
Bible we don't believe that all of the
Bible is the Word of God but we do
believe that within the Bible you do
find elements which do represent the
Word of God among those are the
repetitive teaching over and over again
from the first commandment on to the
teachings of Jesus that know your God is
one God God is one that that's a common
thread throughout the teachings of all
of the prophets another common thread is
that you have a chain of Revelation our
Creator sent down prophets to bear
revelation to the people as guidance to
them every time that revelation became
corrupted God did what he sent another
prophet this is why prophethood didn't
stop with one man this is why we didn't
just have Abraham and that's it we
didn't have just Moses record the Old
Testament and that's it no the Old
Testament became corrupted and that is
provable okay and once that happened
what was necessary for Jesus Jesus
Christ to be sent to what to the lost
sheep of Israel lost why because they
lost their the purity of their
revelation okay so believe in God is one
God believe in the chain of Revelation
believe in the prophets who bore the the
message of our Creator to mankind
included in that package is the Old
Testament Testament prediction of three
prophets to follow John the Baptist
Jesus Christ our one
and - and that leaves one final profit
we find in the New Testament as we
discussed previously in the passage
relating to Alice Parakletos Jesus
Christ referencing another Paraclete
another of whatever Jesus Christ was
because he was described as apparently
and that would be the third and final
profit the job of everybody out there
now is to consider in the light of what
we have discussed who might be that
final profit who might what might be the
revelation that he bore we as Muslims
accept that final prophet as Muhammad
peace be upon him the final revelation
has the Holy Quran that is the subject
of another of my books and hopefully
some more of these sessions in the last
few seconds thank you very much may God
a mighty roar to help people how can
people get a hold you to read some of
your articles and eBooks find my
articles find my books find me on level
truth calm or eighth scroll calm thank
you very much once again thank you thank
you may god almighty allow and watch
thank you and if you'd like to say hello
to dr. Brown if you'd like to pay him a
visit level to calm a scroll calm take
it up with him if there's some things
you feel he missed no problem you can
reach them there and now that was it
it's very simple it's logical yes many
people complained claimed to be prophets
many people can claim to be on the truth
but look at the teachings see if the
evidence they present is testable and
Islam has the testable evidence the
verbatim Word of God the Quran is a
living miracle to this day just have an
open heart and open mind everything that
it calls you to is good
it teaches original goodness it doesn't
teach original sin
it teaches pure monotheism establishing
a direct dialogue with the created-- or
the one who created everything in this
universe and it teaches you to develop
yourself to be the best human being in
the world to be just to be on justice
great morals great character doesn't
teach terrorism killing innocent men
women and show it does not have nothing
to do with this and if you'd like what
we have to say here today call the
number on the screen 1 866 - Islam to
learn more until next time
peace be unto you